ich bin ja eigentlich ein ruhiger und
besonnener mensch doch manchmal gehe
selbst ich unter die decke und das ist
heute der fall heute hat die cdu einen
offenen brief an rieso geschrieben als
reaktion auf sein video zerstörung der
cdu mit millionen reichweite ich möchte
jetzt mal an das thema wissenschaftlich
herangehen klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es meistens spannendes heinz
videos heute nicht aber wenn ihr dran
sein wollt dann abonniert den kanal
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
die cdu hat sich entschieden nicht
inhaltlich auf das video von risiko
einzugehen
vielleicht liegt es daran weil
inhaltlich sehr schwer etwas daran
auszusetzen ist zwar wird argumentiert
von paul zielmarke generalsekretär der
cdu dass dieses video populistisch sei
und schlecht recherchiert doch was den
klimawandel angeht da habe ich mich ein
wenig in den letzten jahren informiert
liegt er hier vollkommen falls rieso hat
absolut korrekt argumentiert das was
hier die deutsche bundesregierung
namentlich die cdu und die spd
veranstalten ist ja praktisch völkermord
man kann es nicht anders sagen und wenn
am ende des offenen briefes gesagt wird
dass man niemanden zerstören würde
dann muss man sagen doch wegen 20.000
arbeitsplätzen in der industrie rund um
kohlekraftwerke werden millionen
menschenleben geopfert denn das ist die
konsequenz wenn das klimaziel das im
pariser klimaabkommen erklärt worden ist
nicht erreicht wird nämlich maximal 1,5
bis 2 grad temperaturerhöhung auf
unserer erde und selbst da ist noch
strittig welche konsequenzen es haben
wird schon gehen die ersten inseln unter
und wir werden von zahlreichen wetter
katastrophen heimgesucht sei es sinn für
tiger regen oder eine komplett heiße
nordhalbkugel wie im letzten jahr
wirklich schlimm und das kann man nicht
von der hand weisen
und wenn rieso hier zur zerstörung der
cdu aufruft dann hat er seine gründe man
kann natürlich darüber streiten ob man
das jetzt auf cdu spd und fdp und auch
zur nichtwahl dieser parteien aufruft
aber über eines kann man nicht streiten
die klimapolitik in deutschland ist
komplett verfehlt und das sage nicht nur
ich das sagt nicht nur wieso das sagen
auch die science is for future
wissenschaftler mehr als 20.000 haben
unterschrieben und gesagt wir sind die
profis schönen gruß an christian lindner
fdp vorsitzender wir sind die profis und
wir sagen euch ihr macht dir alles
falsch und das ist tatsächlich so wenn
man die cdu und die spd und die fdp
ihrer klimapolitik bewertet dann
versagen sie hier auf voller linie jetzt
wird argumentiert ja deutschland trägt
ja nur zwei prozent zum co2 ausstoß
weltweit bei aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen deutschland ist eines der top
5 industrieländer weltweit wenn wir das
machen wenn wir das pariser
klimaabkommen nicht einhalten können
auch alle anderen sagen ja wenn die das
nicht machen warum sollen wir das tun
und da hängen dann die 98 anderen
prozent dran an co2 ausstoß
menschengemachten co2 ausstoß der jedes
jahr die temperatur ansteigen lässt wir
hatten in den letzten jahren die
heißesten sommer überhaupt aller zeiten
seit der erfassung von klimadaten und
das nicht ohne grund weil eben die
klimagase immer weiter zunehmen was
daran liegt dass zusätzliches co2 sehr
wenig aber zusätzliches co2 in die
atmosphäre gelangt und dadurch die
temperaturen steigen denn co2 ist am
klimagas ein treibhausgas wie andere
gase auch im pariser klimaabkommen haben
wir uns aber insbesondere auf die
reduktion des co2 ausstosses geeinigt
und an diese einigung hält sich die
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht und
klar ist und das sagen
experten dass das zu millionen zu aber
millionen toten führen wird und zur
riesigen flüchtlingsbewegungen wir
können doch hier in deutschland nicht
mit derselben regierung sagen tut uns
leid wir können die klimaziele nicht
erreichen aber auf der anderen seite
geflüchtete aus anderen ländern hier
einfach nicht aufnehmen wollen
wir sind geradezu dazu verpflichtet weil
wir sind die verursacher dieser flucht
mit unserer konsumgesellschaft wir
müssen also hier dringend etwas tun und
wenn 3ds for future events and is for
future wenn parents for future und so
weiter und so fort und wenn alle sagen
wir müssen hier was ändern dann ist
einfach höchste eisenbahn geboten und in
der regierung wird einfach der schuss
nicht gehört es gab ja dieses wunderbare
gespräch zwischen luisa neubauer und
unserem bundeswirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier wo er mit pauken und trompeten
einfach untergegangen ist er hatte keine
argumente denn es gibt keine argumente
dagegen dass die welt durch die
steigenden temperaturen zerstört wird
also wir müssen handeln
die bundesregierung muss handeln und was
ich nicht verstehe nach fukushima was
wirklich im prinzip nur eine lokale
katastrophe war aber das was wir hier
machen ist eine riesige katastrophe wird
zerstören unseren planeten und machen
ihn zumindest für unsere spezies und
noch ein paar millionen andere
unbewohnbar
das sechste massenaussterben hat bereits
begonnen wir vermüllen unsere welt mit
plastikmüll wir müssen hier dringend
etwas tun und wenn die cdu hier auf ihre
mitglieder und ihre wähler verweist dann
muss man sagen erstens das sind eure
wähler die gehören nicht zu euch die
haben nur für euch gestimmt weil sie
eine vernünftige politik erwarten
zweitens euren mitglieder sind nicht
unbedingt die entscheider denn viele
entscheidungen werden in gremien
getroffen und von euren na ja wieso hat
ein paar beispiele gezeigt
professionellen politikerinnen und
politikern also leute hört die
wählerinnen und wähler hört vor allem
auf die junge generation und ändert die
jetzt eure politik
fukushima war dagegen wirklich ein
kleines schlimmes singuläres ereignis
aber was jetzt uns droht und auf was ihr
viel zu schwach viel zu wenig reagiert
ist eine weltweite katastrophe eine
zerstörung unserer lebenswelt also wieso
hat recht man kann es nicht von der hand
weisen und alle diffamierungen jetzt
kommen sie noch wieder mit fake accounts
das ist wirklich zum haareraufen leute
die wir uns auf diesem video sind echt
ich kenne zufällig die regeln von views
auf youtube und wie sie gezählt werden
da wird jeder view aussortiert und das
höchst zuverlässig also diese bis gerade
noch fünf millionen wahrscheinlich jetzt
schon 678 millionen views sind absolut
realistisch und passt auf die leute
verstehen was er sagt und vielleicht
liest sich auch der ein oder andere sein
60-jähriges quellen dokument durch weil
er hat dort eine menge arbeit
reingesteckt natürlich hat der
zugespitzt und liebe medien die das
jetzt kritisieren ihre spitzt auch ohne
ende zu
das ist ein absolut legitimes
journalistisches mittel also in diesem
sinne ich kann nur sagen geht zur wahl
welt die parteien die eure interessen
vertreten
redet mit euren eltern großeltern onkels
tanten verwandten bekannten und
überzeugt sie die parteien zu wählen die
wirklich für euch eintreten und die
unsere erde retten wollen weil das ist
wirklich jetzt der punkt es geht nicht
darum irgendwie noch was aufzuhalten
jetzt geht es darum unsere welt zu
retten unsere bundesregierung ist da
offensichtlich nicht so in der lage
also müssen wir jetzt auf europäischer
ebene was tun und eben genau diese
parteien wählen also geht zur wahl
hashtag diesmal wähle ich und ansonsten
sehen wir uns also am 26 mai im
wahllokal bis dann bleibt dran